اسمح لي سيد مشالي
الامر في ما سالته انك طالبان لم يختلفوا
او لم ينقلبوا على ما قالوا فانهم لم
يقولوا ابدا انهم تغيرون بل كان هناك من
كان دائما
يحاول ان
يعرفهم بانهم تغيير الا وهو خالد زكي لم
نسمع من الطالبان انه قالوا انهم
دائما كانت هناك دعايه همم لا نعرف ما
كانت وراءها كانت بعام خليجان وكان دائما
يكون من هؤلاء التغيير يحترمونه الانسان
المدنيه وغيرها فهم لم يتغيروا ولم
يتغيروا في شيء
النقطه الثانيه من سؤالك كشفوا عن وجه
الحقيقي
فهذا الوجه
اذ كان معروف وما زال هو معروف نعم لم
يتغير في شيء ومن يوم ان دخلوا الى كابل
بقوه ومعاونه امريكيه فلم لم يفعلوا الا
امنوا النسوان او بناتنا اخواتنا من العمل
من التعليم وليس في الجامعات وليس في
كليات
العصريه كما يسمونها بل حتى في مدارس
دينيه ربما سمعتم بانهم اغلقوا مدرسه كانت
تحتوي على 4,000 بنت مدرسه دينيه محضر في
مدينه العراق وكانت تابعه للشيخ جليل
هذا وايضا جامعه السلام كانت جامعه السلام
وهذه المدارس كانت تفرض الحجاب كامل حتى
في ايام الجمهوريه واتمنى نحن في حكومتنا
لم نعرضهم لان الحجاب هو جزء من الدين حتى
اغلق مدارس واغلق حلقات نهائيا كانهم ومنذ
اول يومها ام ضد المراه وضد نزام مدني وضد
مجتمع المدني فلم يغير فيه شيء